[Music]
welcome back to the things
did you ever wonder what it would be
like if elsa and jack frost had a
face-off
the frozen queen and the rise of the
guardian's protagonist can both
manipulate ice and snow
but whose power is strongest and what
might lead to their battle
they might have been pulled together
romantically through their shared
experience
but when jack turned evil and decided
they should take over arendelle and
create a permanent freeze
elsa's love for her sister anna and
arendelle's people was stronger than her
love for jack
see what it looks like when jack and
elsa shoot their ice-cold powers at each
other
spoiler alert it's epic
[Music]
oh yeah
oh yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
can we take it higher what do you desire
let me see that fire fire hey
[Music]
so
[Music]
is
don't put it on me
[Music]
what do you desire
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you